hi three a check out our fancy March
shop make you fancy calm and don't
forget to dance make it fancy so this is
one of my proudest achievements there's
a lot of science that goes into it
making croissants is notoriously hard
because there are so many different
elements that go into just this one
piece of flaky pastry while I stand by
the fact that you should probably just
support your local Baker and buy a
croissant it was a really cool
experience having to make croissants
from scratch and it's something that
although I probably won't do again I'm
glad I did there's so many different
ways to make croissants and a lot of
recipes online that try to make it
easier but after testing a lot of
different ways I found that the old
classic tried-and-true way was
definitely the way to go and that
cutting corners was not gonna work from
start to finish I think it takes about
three days to make a batch of croissants
so again this is not a project for the
people who are low on time like I said
there's a lot of different ways to make
croissants but I found that doing the
classic method of making a block of
butter and then putting that in the
middle of the dough and folding that up
was far and away the best way to go but
that's why it's also really important
when you're making the croissants like
during that process to keep everything
really cold because if the butter melts
into the dough when you bake it it won't
have those pockets that will expand into
those flakiness and I know this from
experience because I had a few batches
that turned into like a dense bread more
than a few batches lots about this
that's why it's so important that you're
chilling the dough in between rolling
the dough and you're controlling
everything to keep everything really
cold there were some other methods that
you could try like adding softened
butter or adding the butter directly to
the dough but I tried all those and they
did not work so each time you do your
fold in turn you'll like multiply the
amount of layers you get was like three
to nine to 27 I think you end up with
twenty seven layers total but who's
counting
[Music]
of course on tasty videos we try to
simplify everything down and really
break things down into easy-to-follow
steps so it was definitely a big
challenge to break down something as
difficult as croissants into
easy-to-follow steps but I think I did a
pretty good job in this video when you
bake the dough with all those layers of
butter in between the butter will melt
and create co2 and then it expands and
that's why you get those pockets of air
which make a flaky croissant it also is
a really cool project if you already
enjoy baking if you enjoy a challenge
this is definitely something that you
could try to do maybe with your
significant other or your kid it'll be a
good bonding experience no it was I
guess a good bonding experience with
myself
[Music]